il paraît que des blocages de venir
enseigner ici à partir de cet été qui
sans rien
j'ai rien mois contre le côté au bout du
rouleau mois ci c'est fou et moi c'est
ritary charts je suis ravi que vous
savez ici c'est dingue âgées même pas
encore vu ce type que j'en suis déjà
jaloux refais toi qui est patent vous
avez réussi vous échanger deux mots avec
lui il est dans son mot ils aiment
rester tranquille dans son coin en
faisant mes courses chez le caviste
aujourd'hui je sais à quel point vous
avez le single malt et donc
il ya une différence entre un monde
théorique basé sur un verbiage de merde
philosophique et la réalité de la vie y
est plus de plus près c'est juste qu'il
est fascinant c'est un vrai génie mains
écorchées vif aussi je suis en bas de
grille de vieux jazz pas à écrire parce
que j'agis pas respirer il vous faut une
muse
conçu ce qu'il était intéressant à dire
qu'est ce qui vous prend
c'est quand même une leçon
d'existentialisme plus efficace que
celle d'emmanuel vous êtes tombé juste
j'espère seulement que tu ne tache pas
trop de bruit
tu comprends quand même que je puisse
être jaloux non alors là c'est ridicule
la vérité c'est que j'étais attiré par
elle en dépit du fait que c'était une
âme à la dérive
est ce que vous entendez ce qui se passe
derrière mans c'est à cette hausse donc
que mafia pris forme
je suis complètement perdue il faut que
j'arrête de te voir
je veux te demander pardon pourrait
songer que je te poser
borloo de quoi s'agit-il ici demeura de
choix esthétiques
des aléas de la vie